and I think too just for her if you're
having problems with this with other
people opening up and being vulnerable
it's also very hard for people to be
vulnerable because a lot of people don't
want to do that because they're afraid
of getting hurt
cuz when you open yourselves up and you
get shut down when you decided to open
yourselves up to this human being and
that person gets [ __ ] diced and
sliced up it's like yo [ __ ] I made a
mistake I should have just shut my
[ __ ] mouth and that's what people are
scared of because being vulnerable yet
it does open up a relationship and help
it to grow but you that person also has
to be willing to take that risk because
there is a risk yeah whenever I look at
a situation ever I never say you should
be more vulnerable yeah because I'm not
creating an environment for them to open
up yeah so you know yeah there are
people that are very closed off but
people tend to confined in you or like
though they'll open up when they feel
comfortable yeah most people don't
because they don't feel comfortable yeah
so a lot of the times people don't set
up the right environment for for people
to be able to speak freely yeah and if
you're talking about this in a
relationship sense yeah I mean being
vulnerable with your partner is very
very important um and if somebody finds
that as a sign of weakness you you would
be very much mistaken because being
vulnerable with your partner helps it to
grow a lot there's there are things that
you should really open up and
communicate with your partner in my
personal opinion because who else will
be there for you yeah like who else if
the person that you're gonna spend the
rest of your life with that you're
choose if you're in a monogamous
relationship if that person can't be
there for you in that type of sense then
who like who they're supposed to be your
confidant they're gonna be your family
they're gonna be a wife or a husband and
vulnerability is something that you
should be selective of but it should be
something that you should be able to do
with the partner that you're with
because things can only get better from
that point yeah you might get hurt you
might feel like you made a mistake when
that [ __ ] backfires in your face here
and there but if you do have a healthy
relationship and you guys are
communicating really well that
vulnerability is a [ __ ] must I don't
think in most cases two people know that
they're holding information
back mmm yeah yeah yeah like you know
like most people they don't go
throughout life like hiding [ __ ] like
they're not doing it on purpose no it's
like we all see it because people are
stupid and we see what they're doing but
we have this funny thing called ego that
protects us from seeing ourselves so
like you might see your boyfriend
um hurt over something and then you're
like talk to me about it and then he's
all like I ain't heard what the [ __ ]
what are you talking about yeah
they don't even know they don't even
know they don't know that they something
just bothered them mm maybe you got a
word it different maybe it's like he
doesn't like to be called hurt even
though that is what's happening but when
you want someone to be vulnerable with
you you got to use their words and
things that make them comfortable
instead of saying no you need to say it
like me mm-hmm
in admit that you're hurt and be open
and vulnerable like that'll never open
people up yeah it's and I understand
what it's like to not want to be open
and vulnerable with somebody because in
a previous podcast when I first started
this podcast and I'm Ariel on I told her
that's something that she didn't know
but I had a huge issue of saying of
showing her that I missed her or kind of
being more affectionate towards her
because I just had this weird roadblock
a fear of like well what if you [ __ ]
leave so what's the woman showing you
the side to me anyways you know there's
there's fear to that type of [ __ ]
especially and it depends on you know
what stage of your relationship you are
with this person cuz it took me like
three years for me to finally open up
and really be vulnerable with there
could be and you have to even know that
you had that fear yeah it took a while
for me to kind of register because most
people will just react mm-hmm and then
just be like oh I can make maybe crack a
joke instead of saying I miss you or
whatever right until someone points it
out and they're like what oh all this
because it will be on some [ __ ] like if
I if I kind of said like hey I really
missed you and I appreciate you this
[ __ ] would be in a bunch of a group of
our friends is you know what David said
yesterday he said he read my [ __ ]
[ __ ] like dope that's between us what
would you do that is so funny I just
but it's because she thinks it's really
cute yeah and she she finds it really
adorable but she wants to parade it
around like a trophy yeah like she feels
great like this is an odd thing and I
understand it I'm just like she's gonna
be an awesome mom just embarrassing the
[ __ ] out of her kid you know what little
little Kang Kang said Kang Kang said
that he loves his teddy bear he's like
oh god you just embarrassed our son I
renamed him Kang Kang so he's already in
the baby okay little K little Kang Kang
did yeah I think everyone should learn
to be a little more vulnerable though
but in order to for that to happen it
takes a lot of courage in it and what
what I mean by courage is being able to
look inside and this is some next-level
maturity [ __ ] where a lot of people
can't even do it and they're like 60 or
70 oh do men you would think through
some of these old people men you would
think that the moment they try to even
say something is cute or adorable you
would think that they would have a
[ __ ] heart attack yeah cuz up because
it's not manly enough right like even
saying like for example like my dad has
never said sorry if that fool said sorry
I think he would have a heart attack oh
man you know it's like are you sorry
yeah but I saw a Korean never say sorry
dude they never will yeah and it's
because it makes you vulnerable you I
make them lose yeah makes them wrong oh
yeah I think old Asian people just hate
[ __ ] losing and being wrong my no
mistakes no mistakes whatsoever I think
my dad could literally like place a bed
of knives upright on the floor trip me
and have me landing it and he'll be like
you should have just been born with a
steel body you know you should have
looked where you were walking huh you
should do the shrimp turn your body
sideways and missed all the knives like
that's just how that man is like it's a
blonde you should a continue Taekwondo
if you were never slow pad you'd be
Pat's
past it like a cat and then you jump on
your feet like at this one okay my mom
too she said this funny thing did your
mom is your mom involving more than your
dad it seems like I think my dad has a
ball past my mom really my mom is the
most stubborn he
oh [ __ ] she she's so [ __ ] stubborn
she says she goes all the things that
you hate about me that I do don't even
think about changing it cuz I will never
change Wow yes she goes you be an adult
and you live with it for the rest of
your life she's odd she's very
self-aware
she's very so she knows she's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah she just was like no this
is how mommy is you either accept it or
don't accept it I'm not gonna change me
I'm like okay well I guess I just have
to deal with that then cuz for example
like this woman cannot keep a secret to
save her life
she still can't do it yeah and I keep
falling for the trap I'm the dumb one
yeah like you could you could tell me
I'm not gonna tell anybody I'm like this
my mom I could trust her three seconds
later she goes I told everybody she's
probably like I'm not gonna tell nobody
and she goes out of her way to start
calling people up instead of like you
know when people slip at a secret it's
like could during a conversation yeah
your mom probably intentionally calls
people up and lets them know your secret
dude verbatim what she said in Korean
she goes I feel that if I don't tell
somebody I'm going to internally explode
what from guilt from like because she
just can't hold a secret she just has to
tell somebody I'm like you are the worst
person ever if I ever commit a crime she
is not allowed to be there as a witness
she will I have to tell you David killed
that person she he cared him so bad and
all the crimes that you did in the past
all of it my mom is such a unique person
like I think I'm very grateful to happen
because at least I could talk to her
very casually and very fun I didn't
realize how uncommon my relationship
with my mom is I mean yeah especially in
a Asian household where like how close
you guys are yeah like we talked about
everything I mean like Meryl I got into
a little fight yesterday and I talked to
her this morning about it just a vent
yeah and then I felt way better yeah and
my mom too whenever she fights with my
dad she calls me up and she [ __ ]
about this for this she called me up the
other day dude about my dad she goes god
damn your dad did it again I'm like what
am i what did our dad do she goes you
know how he just [ __ ] acts like he's
just a smartest [ __ ] person on
earth Wow and every time I do something
wrong he goes oh you don't even know how
to do that she's like [ __ ] you
I don't need a douche yeah she goes well
there's a lot of [ __ ] that he doesn't
know how to [ __ ] do he goes how many
times have I told about the price of
that product and he's always asked Oh
how much is it how much is it what are
you [ __ ] dumb he's just stupid - and
then she's literally talking [ __ ] about
him as he's sitting right next to her
Wow and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
my dad's just in the background like
your mom's at it again and I could hear
him just mouthing off in the back and
she's talking [ __ ] about him to me on
the phone as he's sitting next to it
dude they have some passionate fights
there huh dude they're old they still
fight super passion I mean not as bad as
it used to be when I was younger but
they still get into it they still fight
it's because they work together 24
[ __ ] 7 still they still run the
business together they see each other
right when they wake up all the way to
the till they sleep they don't have a
break from each other